welcome back to new rock stars it's me
mt and mega spoiler warning for the
piece of high octane ass kicking cinema
that is shanxi and the legend of the ten
rings coming up because hey hey my girl
jai ling came out on top as the leader
of the ten rings in hot damn do you just
love to see it that's a strong
independent woman right there ten rings
tom brady and ariana grande only knew
about seven and this video is brought to
you by squarespace from websites and
online stores to marketing tools and
analytics squarespace is the all-in-one
platform to build a beautiful online
presence and run your business now that
jai ling no longer qualifies as a small
business owner where could we see her
next in how far will we see her new 10
rings authority reach in the mcu i mean
the end of shanghai promises the return
of the ten rings after all so let's go
on ahead and speculate just how that's
gonna be my nerd babies because i'm
thinking that we might just see
xialing's rings doing their thing in
ant-man and the wasp quantomania roadies
armor wars sam wilson's first captain
america film and or hawkeye but hey have
you ever tried to navigate a stolen
sports car through a shifting bamboo
jungle maze to the mystical gates of
tylo let morris be your guide because
styled like a vintage kaiju poster this
exclusive new shirt features the
adorable six-legged headless winged
chicken pig that stole the show in
chiang chi and the legend of the ten
rings and if you buy both shanxi
t-shirts together you can get 10 off
your purchase but as we all know the 10
rings is an international criminal
organization that is all about weapons
but more specifically being on the
cutting edge of military weapon
technology this would probably explain
why their logo is literally one of the
most badass weapons to ever appear on
earth and it's also why they kidnapped a
whole ass tony stank to make fully
functional jericho missiles in a cavern
with nothing but a bloody box of
knickknacks and we also know from
ant-man 1 that the 10 rings in hydra
have a very close business relationship
as we can see one of wenwu's men working
alongside former shield head of defense
and current hydra douche canoe mitchell
to stabilize your country carson to
purchase a yellowjacket army to take
over the world by swarm that was a
flying insect pun
but of course anthony and his amazing
friends interrupted that deal but not
without hydra agent mitchell carson
pocketing some pin particles for himself
i cannot believe that thief would steal
from a thief who stole from a thief
thief who thieved a thief from the chief
of police
good grief this all being said if when
we was partnering with hydra to
potentially possess the power of the
pimp article to manufacture many
militaries of many murder men then
xiling may have inherited that working
relationship with hydra as well and with
it the very keys to the next big energy
race in the mcu the race for quantum
energy and this is a race alluded to by
that well-dressed backstabbing son of a
birch in ant-man and the wasp sunny
birch now you can forget nano tech
forget a.i forget cryptocurrency quantum
energy is the future it's the next gold
rush that's so and since it's nearly
been a whole last decade in the mcu
since carson stole those pym particles
in ant-man 1 to xiling's takeover in
chongqi the 10 rings and hydra have had
a long ass time to attempt to reverse
engineer that secret hank pym krabby
patty formula that is you know the pin
particles something that i'm sure would
have taken the boys at the hydra chum
bucket a lot less time if you know karen
zola didn't sell struck
after that interest was already
sufficiently peaked enough after work
got out at some dummy with pimp articles
beat up the avenger formerly known as
clarence and successfully stole some of
the avengers the term quantomania
in ant-man of the wasp quantomania could
be referring to the forces and powers of
the world going crazy over quantum
energy like sunny birch predicted
putting zhai ling and the ten rings in
the perfect position to be the top
distributor of quantum energy and
quantum energy weaponry in the world
possibly allied with other nefarious
forces in the shadows of the mcu like
roxon energy which we see is still doing
its best amazon and tijuana impression
in the year 2050 in loki big rocks on
energy but this also opens the door for
the 10 rings and friends to potentially
unlock the very secrets of the quantum
realm itself and with it the secrets of
time travel which could potentially make
scott lang the marty mcfly he always
wanted to be somebody peed my pants and
xiling's business partner mitch the
carson the perfect biff tannen but
mostly because he got bipped in the face
by hank pym got him and hey kang has got
to learn the secret of time travel
somehow because that was truly a
pandora's box that tony opened up in end
game and don't forget now mitch the
used to be head of defense at
shield meaning that he has probably
spent decades personally overseeing the
experimentation and activation of ghost
when she was a secret hydra assassin
like bucky so this could have fueled the
10 rings in hydra's interest to build
armies of many murder men and big bad
baba yaga if you want to start a
business you need a good online presence
and how will people know you're a
legitimate dog hypnotist if you don't
have a legitimate looking website for
dog hypnotizing squarespace is an
all-in-one platform to build a beautiful
online presence and let the world know
how you mesmerize a maltese how do you
do it i do not know just kidding i do i
run a business squarespace lets you
present members only gated content
connect your social media accounts
present video content and all the other
cool features to give you a super cool
super functional website for your hobby
or your business and squarespace will
even sell you a url collect the emails
of interested folks and send custom
newsletters filled with tricks on how to
convince your pet dog that they're
actually a cat so head to
squarespace.com for a free trial and
when you're ready to launch go to
squarespace.com
new rockstars to save 10 off your first
purchase of a website or domain that's
squarespace.com new rockstars for 10 off
your first purchase of a website or
domain but hey now xiling and carson
never did get that yellowjacket armor
for their wars which they paid
psychobaldi good blood money for which
also puts jai ling as head of the 10
rings who are historically iron man
enemies in the comics to play a major
role in marvel's upcoming armor wars
series as well because much like in the
armor war series the secrets of the iron
man armor can be repurposed in many
interesting ways like look this one even
has titty blasters but even if it's not
to build an army of iron ant-man the
iron man technology has been sought
after by the world since don cheadle's
very first appearance as james rhodes in
iron man 2 like everyone's been all
about trying to get the secrets of tony
stark's armor and since the 10 rings
always needs to have the coolest weapons
on the block xiling is 100
gonna be gunning for the secret of
tony's stark of the covenant but hey
speaking of secrets remember that
post-credits scene from falcon of the
winter soldier when sharon power broker
carter decided to make it a legal phone
call mere steps away from the place
where she just got pardoned well i think
that the person that sharon carter is
sharing that hot government gossip with
could be none other than the ten rings
new leader jailing herself because you
know
girl talk yeah that's right i know what
you ladies are up to when you go to the
bathroom together y'all talking about
illegal prototype weapons and but
no seriously sharon carter specifically
mentions prototype weapons on her
mysterious phone call and not only would
this make sense for this to be xi'ling
or 10 rings contact because of their
long history of die hard interest in
black market arms dealing but it would
also serve to explain sharon carter's
seemingly quick and sudden rise to
broken power and influence in magipore
because xiling probably had a soft spot
for sharon as a fellow woman who was
cast aside underestimated and forgotten
and personally i hope jai ling is
assembling her own team a bad ass woman
to take over the whole world because
frankly the patriarchy
it's a bunch of and speaking of
bad ass women xiling's rings could also
show up in hawkeye through one contessa
valentina allegra de fontaine carmen san
diego nina pinta santa maria though
val's motives are a bit of a mystery for
now we do know that she does have ties
to hydra in the comics so if vel is a
representative of this new growing brand
of hydra and the ten rings in hydra
already have this established close
working relationship it makes sense for
val to want to manipulate elena to kill
clint because if you remember instead of
going to therapy clinton barton as ronan
spent the five years after the snap
going after the criminal organizations
of the world and they probably want the
revenge for ronan ronining their plans i
hate when my plans are ronin but that is
it for me speculating for today
speculation nation how do you guys think
that gianling's ten rings will factor
into phase four and beyond let us know
below my nerd babies thank you guys so
much for watching this video and please
be sure to hit up new rockstarsmerch.com
to check out our new chiang chi shirts
because morris is not going to wear
himself you can follow me at
mastertainment on twitter if you want to
see me tweet some weird but most
importantly please follow new rockstars
on twitter because tyler's killing it
just kills it all day long and we post
some really great stuff there and please
hit that notification bell on youtube so
you can get notifications whenever we
upload a new video thanks again for
watching go watch chiang chi three more
times goodbye
[Music]
you